M so how's work going it's been a little
stressful yeah we've been trying to
relaunch the website with Innovative AI
functionality but the backend DB keeps
crashing in beta I don't know what you
just said what do
that so basically the project that I've
been working on for the past two years
has been extremely delayed and we've
been trying to have it operational by
the time I go on maternity leave yeah
that sounds like a lot plus we have Josh
and Coco every other week and Tyler's
going to be super busy with the new
restaurant and I don't know where that
leaves us time for each
other oh hi okay no doubt things are
going to be different but you can still
find the magic in those little moments
between the big moments the most
important thing is that you need to make
time to take care of yourself yes
because if you don't take care of
yourself you are useless to everyone
else M and I'm talking it's the little
little things like like if he lets you
sleep in or a spontaneous foot massage
ew feet are gross oh what's wrong with
feet I love a good foot massage as a
matter of fact if you wouldn't mom you
get your stinky feet away from me I'm
nauseous and those feet did not
help let me get this straight you've
been extra tired lately emotional
nauseous what
I've got some extra home pregnancy tests
left in the bathroom no way I'm not
pregnant I can't believe I'm pregnant oh
I'm so
excited I took
two we're going have babies the
same
yay
[Music]